today i'm going to show you how to play
ed sheeran's song lego house
in the key of g now the actual song
where ed sheeran plays it and sings it
is in the key of b
now what's the difference between that
i'll say a bit more about that later on
but first i'm just going to show you the
chords and how it works
so there are three sort of sets of
chords um
and the orders of chords that you need
to know and we call them chord
progressions so
there's a pattern that sort of repeats
over and over again
and in three sections of the song the
verse the chorus and the bridge
the patterns are all slightly different
they use mostly the same kinds of chords
but in a different order so first i'll
show you the verse
you only really need to do three chords
and they go
they cycle backwards and fours between
them so the three chords are
a g a d and an e minor
okay so if you're i'm not going to talk
about the figurines for those
you can have a look at the video about
the key of g and the chords in it
but uh those are the three chords you
need g d e minor
now what does the actual progression
look like what's the order
um well you're gonna go just from the g
to the d
to the e minor and then backwards again
in the same order
um to the d and then to the g so it's
kind of like a
math teacher it's like a palindrome so g
d e minor
d g and back again so like so
g d e minor
d g and you're now back to the start
d e minor
d g that's the whole progression for the
whole verse that just repeats over and
over again this is what it sounds like
um
so you can see that g d e minor d
g that sort of back and forth repeats
every line of the verse over and over
again
so a couple of things now to note about
them you don't hold you might have
noticed you don't hold
each chord for the same amount of time
for instance that d
it sort of pops in it's more like a
transition chord if you like
uh and you can sort of see why if you
think about
um this this highest string
at the moment when i'm playing uh the g
major chord it's playing a g that that
note is a g
when i go to the d the next chord
the top string is now playing an f sharp
which is
one semitone down so it's sort of like a
transition and then when you play the e
minor
the general sound is of an e so you're
sort of going g
f sharp e you can even leave off that so
you get that
and you can hear it progress down so
that's kind of a very very common
progression
so if you master the g d e minor that
will serve you pretty well
so again just showing you the d you have
to move to quite quickly
because it's only there for a very very
short amount of time so
you're going to mainly stay on the g and
the e minor like so g
for a little while d e minor
g so that change needs to be really
quick
so like i said in the how to practice
video you want to move
as you're practicing very very slowly
make sure all of your fingers are in
exactly the
right spots and move them all
individually
really slowly so you can really get that
changed down
and and nail it and not make any
mistakes as you do it
okay so there's the verse um chords
uh now the chorus the chorus starts off
very very similar
it starts off with the g and the d and
the e minor um but you're going to need
an extra
chord which is the c which i'll show you
how it comes in so
um how does it go
so that part's the same g d e minor
and then what it progresses to is
instead of going back to the d
and then back to the g it it flips those
around so it's gonna
do a g and then a d like so
so hold on so let's get that you got g
short d e minor
then a short g to a d onto that
for a little while now for this next pit
we're going to do a g chord into a c
chord
but it's actually a g with a b bass i
mentioned that
um you know sometimes they change the
bass note so instead of playing the full
g which looks like this
and it's got the that's the lowest note
the bass note that's the g
i'm only going to play the fifth string
here a one two three four
five that's the b so it's the a string a
b flat b i'm going to
play that and then move into the c
so i missed which that b and that c
because they're very very close together
it kind of makes it a nicer transition
so that
g with a b bass to a c and then you
finish with the d
a nice short d just like the other um
the other times we play it
and then you're back to the start that
repeats twice for the course so
let's do that all over again so this is
the
b chorus c and then a short d
be back to the beginning g d e minor
g d
g with b bass c and then
d now that's the whole chorus
um it repeats it repeats um that that
same set of chords i think you do it
twice for the horse
okay now after that d depending on what
happens next you play different chords
so
if you're going to verse 2 after that d
you'll go back to the original
g d e minor
so um this is one of the reasons that's
a nice simple song in between the
chorus and the verse he just plays the
same chords that he plays in the verse
anyway
so if you're going from the chorus to
the verse you're gonna go
from that last d in the chorus to a g
but when you go from the chorus to a
bridge
well not a bridge the bridge uh it's
different so instead of going
from that d to a g
i'll show you the bridge chords now so
um that final d in the chorus
will go to an e minor to a d
to c back to a d
and then a c and a short d to end
so let me let me actually play it with
the with the vocal
so this is the end of the chorus
an outreach
yeah so it goes back to the pre-chorus
which is the same as the verse anyway
so let me go through those chords again
with the timing so this is the end of
the
chorus how it sounds
so here's the bridge now e minor
short d c
hold on to this d hold on to the c
and then a short d and you're off into
the
um the last pre-chorus which is the same
as the verse
which is g d e minor
okay so those are the orders of the
chords and um you're like oh that went
by really quickly don't worry you can
look in the description and all of the
orders of the chords are written down
there
a couple of things to note about um
the rhythm and how that changes so
um because i'm just playing with an
acoustic guitar and that's all i'm using
um what the drums and the bass guitar
and
his edurance acoustic guitar all of the
things that those do together
as they rise in intensity and drop down
and get quieter you sort of have to do
all of those
things on the one instrument which is
fine acoustic guitar is quite good for
that a piano is also the same
so how do you uh vary between them well
in simple terms you want to make sure
between the verse and the chorus and the
bridge there's a difference in the
intensity that you play so the verse
will be the quietest
um the chorus will be a bit louder and
then the bridge is the loudest the la
the
ending choruses are also quite loud and
then they they settle down
so this is what i mean by and i'll talk
a little bit more about this in a rhythm
video later on
but for instance notice the difference
between playing like this
and now i'm going to play the same
chords but i'm going to play it with
higher intensity
so you can sort of get not only is there
a volume difference because i'm
striking the strings harder in that in
the second version
but i also vary up um the actual rhythm
that i play
to sort of indicate okay i'm generally
i'm playing more notes
um i'm and uh i'm adding more
volume not just by playing harder but by
um how many notes are actually played
so you want to make sure there's that
difference between the verse the chorus
and the bridge otherwise
in terms of tone the whole song will
feel quite flat
and there isn't the same sort of
emotional journey that goes through the
verse and the chorus in the bridge
uh also you'll notice in the actual song
there are times when
he stops playing so that tends to happen
i think just as the um in the pre-chorus
when he sings really fast going into the
chorus that's when he tends to stop so
for instance
now so you can see at the very end
um as he's just about to ramp up into
the chorus instead of just progressing
through
g d e minor d g
on one of the e minors he stops and
uh lets the lets the vocal ring out and
um have more emphasis
so um you want to let that actually ring
it you can either let it ring out
so um
so you can see there that last e minor i
just
uh i played it and i've just let it uh
go quiet naturally
so that's letting this the chord ring
out alternatively
you can stop the chord playing uh by
muting the strings
with the palm of your hand that's that's
strumming so you can see the way that i
did that was
simply you just you just tap the strings
that's all you have to do
so like this
okay um alternatively you can let go of
your fretting hand that'll also do it
which i sort of did there
but the problem with that or the
difference is the the strings you let go
of
will stop playing their notes but the
other strings if they're open if you're
not fretting them with your fingers
they'll just keep on making noise
so it doesn't have the same effect as if
you mute everything
um i think that's mostly it in terms of
how to play the song
now uh why am i playing this in the key
of g
and not in the actual key that the song
is in which is b
so let me talk this through um firstly i
just like my voice
cannot reach the same kinds of high
notes that ed sheeran's voice can hit
hit so what i'll do is what does it mean
that a song is in the key of g versus
the key of b
like b sounds like it's lower than g
because you like earlier in the alphabet
so when you think about musically
there's a um it's
a scale that goes round and round and
round so here's the note g
where is b in relation to g well at
least the way i'm playing it
um i would go up i would go higher so i
would say g
g sharp a b
flat b so there's the note b
and there's the g and there's a four
one two three four semitone
difference between those two notes and
therefore between those two keys
so going from b the original down to g
makes a lot more manageable for the
vocal now
that process of changing the chords is
called transposing
so you're taking all of the chords from
the family of b
and moving them down to um all of the
chords in the in the
um family in the key of g now suppose
you do actually want to play along you
have no interest
in singing the actual song you're like
yeah no that's not my thing
um not really my thing either but anyway
um how would you change it
um you could change the actual shapes of
the chords that you play so instead of
playing a g
i could play an actual b shape like so
um and then i could change all of the
chords uh
accordingly anyway
but a simpler way especially if you want
to play with the nice easy chords that
belong to the key of g
is you can take your caper if you've got
one and you remember i said that the key
of g
is four semitones lower than the key of
b
so if i want to go from g to b i've got
to go four semitones up
so you get your capo and four semitones
means you put it on the fourth fret
like so so now i'm going to play all the
same shapes but i'm going to play them
up here
and they're going to sound instead of
sounding like this which is in
uh without the camera
adding on the capo up at fret 4 will
make him sound like this
so you've gone up to the key of b now
without any extra effort in some
in fact some people would argue that i'm
playing the chords up here are a little
bit easier in some ways but
anyway i'll talk about that another time
um when i talk about barre chords and
voicings
different chord voicings which will make
a lot more sense when you're actually
when you know
some of the different chords and
different keys so
if you want to play along with with the
cd or on the radio or something like
that
pop your capo on four and then you can
use those
chords or alternatively you could just
leave it open
and you can learn the um well later on
we'll learn
the chords that belong to to this key
and then you can play them along like
that if your voice can hit it
because if you want to sing okay